welcome back to dc thursday i'm pete
soderling i'm the founder of data
council in the data community fund
and i'm your guide through the modern
data ecosystem which is
expanding and growing at an amazing clip
we just had our data council in austin
last month and we had 600
of the top professionals in the space
dozens of startups dozens of investors
and it was amazing to get everyone
together again so there's proof to us
that there's no lack of interest in the
space and
as you know um every other week or so we
bring you
an amazing personality who's working
either on an open source project or some
data tech or a startup
and today is no exception we have jeremy
stanley with us
who is the cto and co-founder of nomelo
jeremy was previously the vp of data
science at instacart
and uh prior to that he was also at sail
through and collective in new york city
um which is where we met so jeremy i
want to welcome you to the show
thank you pete so excited to be here
really looking forward to this
conversation
i think it was probably
10 or so years now that we've that we've
met um
when you were in new york and
i i think i'm not sure if it was
collective or sale through one of the
two but um you're working on data i mean
even before
running data at sale through you're
working as a cto at collective which is
a meaningful ad tech company in new york
and at tech companies as anyone who's
been an engineer in new york city knows
always had like meaningful scale and
sort of interesting data challenges
even before the term data engineering
was a thing
there were ad tech companies who
basically had data engineering like
practices because of all the data that
you have so
i'm curious to maybe we should start
there and um you know how did that sort
of impact your career and
impact your appreciation of what the
challenges behind data scale really
meant
yeah so you know i actually i started my
career in data
20 years ago which dates me um and you
know i i graduated from school
yeah around the year 2000 and there it
was no good job opportunities as the
bubble had burst i was studying math i
knew i was going to be one of the best
math professionals right one of the best
math professors and so i wanted to go
into an applied domain and a convince an
insurance company
to hire me and that convinced myself
that maybe i'd become an actuary
i took several tests and i was like no
no no i don't want to spend a whole
career studying the insurance domain and
i convinced the company that hired me
that we could use data to make better
underwriting decisions for life
insurance
and i had no idea what i was doing um i
had a few textbooks i really didn't
understand databases i was trying to
code everything myself in c plus
it was a nightmare it was a mess but i
learned a tremendous amount and i ended
up moving to new york after that from
kansas and i spent the first five years
of my career in financial services using
data to build models to predict
behavior of you know different different
entities it could be
medical malpractice claims for
physicians or you know the chance that a
coal mine was going to collapse and
cause a disaster
and so really generally smaller data
sets there but really cutting my teeth
on how do you effectively use data and
what are all of the different ways that
you can get stuck there right ranging
from you know overfitting to data
quality issues to you know not not
effectively measuring what it is you're
actually trying to accomplish
um so i i saw the ad tech ecosystem
burgeoning in new york i knew that data
was massive and there was a huge
opportunity to begin to optimize
advertising a lot of a lot of things
were very very simple you know
retargeting worked well using data with
no real optimization but beyond that
there wasn't much and so i jumped into
ad tech um and really had to figure out
how to build
the the modern data stack you know for
deploying machine learning and analytics
apps you know before the modern data
stack existed you know buying
many millions of dollars worth of
hardware you know
data centers and uh duct taping and
gluing things together to to build
products and and to differentiate
and so it was fun to be able to kind of
build these things from the ground up
and see all the pain um and then now to
see the whole ecosystem just making so
much so many things easier right now one
person can accomplish what you know 50
people uh would have would have been
required to do you know five or ten
years ago it's amazing
yeah isn't that true so you were
probably building early data in
collective in what 2009
or so yeah that's right yeah yeah so we
were using hadoop extensively we were
using uh nitiza as you know a hardware
uh mpp system that predated you know
redshift and then snowflake and bigquery
um
[Music]
yup got it
um well that's that's fascinating and
yeah you've been in a long time um so so
then when you moved to sail through um
what were the big data challenges at
sail through
well the funniest one was that sail
through was built on top of [ __ ] um and
right you know fascinating experience
and opportunity you know [ __ ] allowed
the engineers to write arbitrary you
know uh uh features without having to
worry about the data model they could
just log whatever json they wanted into
[ __ ]
um and that could evolve over time
as they were you know adding new
features
and so it was actually really
challenging to figure out how to build
you know reliable pipelines on top of a
data model that could change at any
moment and had changed you know hundreds
of times without you know a lot of kind
of you know care or thought over the
course of of the company um and so yeah
we were using spark then um and started
using you know data warehouses like
redshift but a lot of the challenges was
how to deal with that unstructured data
and was this decision made i mean a
salesforce was an email marketing
company
early on was the
was it just because they wanted to store
sort of email content documents like
they felt like their business was about
documents therefore [ __ ] made sense or
was there some other
um analysis that that went to that
decision well cl3 was fundamentally
about personalizing email so there were
already you know email platforms that
predated sail through
and they were very difficult to
personalize and so cl3 began with
transactional email right you you are
trying to do something about your
account and you want a confirmation
you know for that account change it
needs to be very personalized and
detailed to your specific profile and
the actions that you took
and so the primary document was all of
the information around the user in their
activity
with with the actual publishing or
product brand that had the relationship
with the customer so they could put
arbitrary the customers like so you've
got like hundreds of publishers your
business insider right big media
publishers or or really large uh
e-commerce brands
typing in arbitrary data about their
users
in uh json format as documents into into
[ __ ] and then using that to trigger
campaigns and activities through email
got it
so from there you moved west
to the bay area and you ended up as vp
data science and instacart which i've
always thought of as a quite a you know
data forward
type of company considering
scale considering logistics considering
all the things that it takes to sort of
deliver a high quality service um to to
a broad set of individuals or customers
um what were some of the main things
that you learned at instacart
yeah i think one thing to realize about
instacart is that it's the kind of
business where it doesn't work without
data and machine learning you just you
can't do that business you can't do
instacart without mobile phones
right with shoppers using those mobile
phones in order to be able to go out and
pick the groceries you also can't do it
without data
it's impossible to have the right
shopping experience for consumers when
they're trying to reflect the inventory
available at every retail store location
and whether or not that's going to be
found on the shelves store location and
you provide a great shopping experience
digitally and it's impossible to
effectively route and utilize an
on-demand shopping workforce in a way
that is going to be efficient for the
business and you know
efficient for the shoppers themselves
and you keep the shoppers happy without
using a tremendous amount of data
so data was in their dna apoorva the
founder
was an engineer at amazon working on
logistics yeah
knew that data was foundational and the
first hires were very very focused on
getting the data right and so i think it
was interesting to see at instacart this
multi-sided marketplace where they could
collect data about
so many activities right you know down
to you know the second uh geolocation of
a shopper's phone inside of a grocery
store picking an item with a specific
skew
right all of this very granular data um
all being captured stored in a cloud
data warehouse
and then everybody at instacart had
access to the data and most people at
instagram were fluent in sql and go in
and write sql queries use the data to
make decisions to build products
and so the the data fluency and
connectivity there was incredibly high
uh and then the other thing that i
really loved about instagram was the the
bias for action and for ownership
you know in the past i always felt like
once i moved into the startup world
that oh startups they move so much
faster than corporations or consultants
and then i got to instagram and i was
like oh wait a second i thought they
moved faster but no instacart is setting
a completely different bar
for
you know an idea exists on monday and
it's in production on friday um you know
and that's the expectation anytime
anything is proposed it's how do we do
it faster how do we learn faster
i think a big part of why that was the
case is because it was such a
complicated system
you know it's this
you can't do anything at instacart
without affecting five or six different
key metrics
right it could be does the customer get
their groceries on time do they get the
actual grocery items that they want um
you know how big is the basket
how fast is a shopper able to pick the
groceries how fast is the delivery are
the shoppers kept utilized
are the shoppers happy with their
experience
you could imagine many changes that
could happen in that platform and they
would have multiple effects in those
metrics right three might get positive
one might come negative and so uh the
need to be able to instrument monitor
conduct rigorous a b tests you know a b
tests at times where like we're going to
change how the routing algorithm works
randomly by day by city
and do an a b test at the day city level
with statistics on top of that to
control for the variation it was pretty
wild you know figuring out what the
implications of your changes were was so
difficult and challenging and data was
such a huge part of that
and i i never thought of this connection
before but it almost feels to me like
the culture of a b testing
um sort of predates a lot of our
um
heavy reliance and dependence on
analytics product analytics and things
like um i feel like that was sort of the
what broke the seal on
many companies understanding the power
of being quote data driven
and this is before we had significant
probably
advancements in cdps or other kinds of
product analytics let alone you know
having data scientists on staff no one
had data scientists on staff
when they had i mean maybe the first
data scientists they got was to actually
sort of analyze a b testing results or
help uh help a product team sort of
properly instrument a b testing in a
statistically valid way and
i never never really dawned on me that
that was almost maybe a precursor
to a lot of the modern
data analytics and bi that we're doing
now obviously we had bi but sort of not
in a statistically meaningful way before
a b testing would you agree yeah so i
would say it's the strongest
relationship is actually the enable of
enablement of machine learning um you
know there are lots of product changes
that you can make that you can eb test a
lot of things that it's actually very
difficult to a b test you have to you
have to have you know some conviction
and move the product in a new direction
and and go for it right and use use kind
of intuition or first principles
thinking to do it
but machine learning i think you can you
can really make rapid progress if you
can set up rigorous a b testing on the
metrics that matter
and it's shocking to me how often um at
instacart or in other places in my
career you can build an amazing machine
learning model that back tests
incredibly powerfully right is very good
at making recommendations that your
people would go on to consume or to
you're predicting the outcome of
behavior
and then you put that into production in
some you know seemingly obvious way and
a b test results are terrible
because of unintended consequences
and it's a feedback loop right these
these machine learning models don't go
into a static system they change the
system
um and so i'll give you a fun example we
built a model to predict the sequence
with which shoppers should pick the
groceries and we ordered the items in
the app
according to that sequence
and if you did that in a way that would
minimize the traveling distance that the
shopper should go through
it was a terrible change
because often it's not it would have
them go to the frozen aisle first
which no one does and they would look at
it and they would go this doesn't make
any sense these groceries aren't going
to be cold by the end of the end of the
trip they would disregard the whole list
and now be confused about how to
navigate
um and so you know the kind of the the
real world implications of the change
and the feedback loops and and what does
it actually mean is is so important um
and so if you can set up really strong
80 tests it gives you that ground truth
and allows you to take a lot more risk
with data upstream
yeah that's fascinating that's a great
example
um well before we get into the um
anonymous and some of the
the lessons that you know drove you to
start that company um i want to take a
little detour because
um you've been one of the tech leaders
that i've always appreciated um for your
writing and
um you actually just published a blog
post um how we shouldn't be talking
about data warehouses we should be
talking about data factories which is
um fascinating fascinating read and i'm
getting a lot of good play in the
ecosystem so i'd recommend that um folks
check that out
um
but you know throughout your career
you've sort of you've been a great
community member of beta council because
you've always been such a prolific
speaker and author and writer and
um i was uh reflecting that your time at
instacart was no different and you know
there are many many blog posts that you
and the instagram team
generated to expose sort of the cool
projects and things that you're working
on and i just wanted to ask you um how
did you get your team members to write
because it can be really hard to get
technical people to do that so i'm
wondering if you have any any tricks or
lessons because i think that a lot of
companies our community aspire to do
more content marketing
um you know in an authentic sort of
helpful way because their teams have so
much embedded knowledge
to share but i think it's hard to get
the ball rolling on from a company
culture to actually get your engineers
to write so i wanted to ask you about
that
yeah so
there's a bunch of things here and i
probably should write about this i've
advised companies on how to do this and
it's been a lot of time on it um
so i think the first thing to ask is why
does the organization want to do it and
oftentimes it's for recruiting purposes
and so you know that needs to be a real
priority for the organization in order
for you to justify investment in it now
you know there are other reasons to do
it um you know namely i think actually
writing things is how you really deeply
understand them in many cases right
until you explain something you don't
really understand it and so it can often
push your thinking forward
and so there's you know uh other
benefits for the organizations obviously
benefits for the individuals and for
their careers
um and so being real explicit with the
leadership team of an organization that
in order to recruit we need to build a
brand in order to build a brand we need
to tell the world about all the cool
things we're doing in order to do that
we need to do it in an authentic way
right we need to be transparent and open
about it and we need to incentivize and
encourage folks to do it um and so
that's the foundation now
the way it dies is as soon as an
executive makes fun of engineers for
publishing blog posts instead of
shipping features
it's gone
right
you know as soon as you say this isn't
this actually this is something we want
to do but if you do it i'm going to i'm
going to
you know um cast shade
right about about you promoting yourself
or your or your work versus being
productive then it can it can really
easily die
um as long as you don't do that you can
build a really thriving approach there
it takes
it takes a lot of effort and energy so
you've got it at instacart we would
regularly have forums where people could
present work that they'd done internally
really valuable to educate across teams
to you know get new ideas and feedback
and to you know build individuals
ability to communicate internally and we
would pick the best of those and and and
push those folks to write content around
them
and i think
it worked for a few reasons one you know
i had invested a bunch of my time in
writing and had shown that some of the
articles could be really impactful in
the community and so people had a model
they could look to that this is
something that can work
and two we would keep a really high bar
and you know it's hard to write it's
still hard for me today to write and so
the bar was kept by having a you know a
series of folks that can edit review
advise
folks on writing um and you can get that
you know at your at your own company you
can get that through your community so i
strongly encourage folks that are
interested in writing to find the five
people that will give them really
critical advice right you know after
you've got that first or second
iteration you go to folks and they'll
give you really thoughtful critical
structural advice about the content
advice that hurts a little bit right but
then you realize oh when i address it
this is so much better and now i'm even
more excited about the article you need
to build that kind of review in order to
put out really good content
for sure and you know i think um you you
continue to do that even at your
advanced stage um the current blog post
for instance has a handful of folks at
the bottom that you um reach out to for
comments and
um obviously there's other folks in the
tech ecosystem that practice similar
practices and i think it's always helped
me as well a lot so i think those are
those are all great tips
um i missed a question that came in
um just relating to some of your your
previous comments
how do you handle or accommodate a
target for prediction
from a different ecosystem or background
than the available data
that you are trying to do effective
event-based predictions
yeah so i think the the the spirit of
this is
in you when you're in a system and you
can't actually collect the outcome that
you care about um and link that outcome
you know to historical data in order to
identify you know and predict the thing
that you really ultimately care about so
an example might be
you know how happy is the is the
customer with the delivery experience
and there's so much bias in collecting
any kind of feedback from your customers
that you're going to end up missing
uh a lot of that information and you're
not going to be able to predict it and
so
and there's you know many many
situations where where this happens and
you i always think about
a
funnel
of you know there's the final uh perfect
piece of data that i would love to have
that if i had it you know i would i
would have the the perfect information
about the event
and then you just need to step back from
that and you know think through well
what are the causal factors that might
lead up to that
what are things that would just be very
strongly correlated with it
and
oftentimes this is where the power of ad
testing comes into play
you back away to the things that you can
measure you think are causally related
or even just strongly correlated to the
outcome that you really care about you
build models to predict those and then
you maybe test them to see how well they
actually perform
um and you know it's interesting i'll
i'll give you a a more concrete example
one of my favorite problems at instacart
was
um you know when should we deliver the
groceries it turns out if you deliver
the groceries
right on time right right the last
minute before the hour ends the customer
is as unhappy
as if you were five minutes late
because it feels like it's late and like
their tents about you actually have to
be there five minutes or ten minutes
early
and so when we were predicting uh
driving times we wouldn't predict the
average driving time or predict the
variance of driving times we would
predict a quantile of driving times
what's the what's the time that we think
there's a 99 chance that the driver is
going to be able to get to this delivery
location and we would then say okay we
want that 99 chance to be five minutes
before the end of the delivery window
and then we would tune those parameters
using a b test to figure out well is 99
right and is five percent right based
upon how customers actually give us
feedback
got it yeah that's a that's a great
example very helpful
um so so i want to kind of move forward
in the in the timeline and um you
started a company a few years ago um an
envelope and
um
i'm
thrilled that i'm a supporter and an
investor from the early days
um but i wanted to sort of understand uh
and and give you the opportunity to
share with the community
um because i believe there's a key
insight that exists behind every company
every startup um so so what was the key
insight that led you to start an
envelope yeah so
i think it's two
key things in combination you know one
is the awareness of what was happening
with
the technology ecosystem
uh around making it incredibly easy for
an organization to now capture every
scrap of data flowing through the
organization and then democratize access
to that
you know throughout throughout everyone
and we saw this happen at instacart and
when you have that two-sided
you know situation of now there's this
huge diversity of data flowing in you
know near real time into a platform that
anybody in the organization can query
build products and analytics on the
surface area for quality
risk goes up exponentially there
um and so at instagram we would
constantly have you know data that would
be you know late missing corrupted um
you know have unexpected changes in it
and it would have lots of downstream
consequences on decisions that were made
um fire drills that were created to
investigate why something happened or
even machine learning models going
wildly off the rails
because they were being fed you know bad
quality data
and so i i knew that this was a problem
that
was going every organization that was
going to be data driven was going to
face this problem
the second insight was the existing
approaches didn't work
um and the the predominant existing
approach is let's just write a bunch of
rules about our data
the uh you know time that the grocery
order is delivered it must be after the
time that it was picked up from the
grocery store
seems obvious right you can just put
that rule into place
instacart had a system that that allowed
us to do this anybody could go in and
write a sql query that would express one
of these rules
and we would assert those rules about
the data
and when i left there were thousands
of these in production
and we didn't have high quality data it
wasn't it wasn't a fixed problem that
didn't solve the issue and it didn't
solve the issue for a variety of reasons
the the main one is that data is just so
much more complex and ever-changing than
a lot of other things that we've thought
about monitoring so i like to compare it
to
if you want to test your code
you can write unit tests that will
definitively test the logic in the code
and you can have pretty good coverage of
your code with unit tests or if you want
to monitor your infrastructure
you know that the cpu utilization on the
database should not go above 60
and you can use your intuition and
understanding of how the database works
to set a monitoring control there
data
data is like huge right it's this it's
this reflection of everything happening
in the real world in your organization
and it's influenced by third parties by
developers by data transformations by
operational changes by humans going in
and doing things there are so many
sources of change and chaos flowing into
this
huge massively multivariate system all
of the time
rules are never going to cut it it's
you're never going to be able to write
all of the rules that would cover all
the edge cases so we constantly found
ourselves fighting these new unknown
unknowns right the next data quality
issue was always something we hadn't
thought to write a rule for
if you do write all the rules good luck
maintaining them right because the
product is going to constantly change
the data model is going to change you
have to reevaluate those rules every
time
and if you try to auto-generate them
you're going to start getting a huge
number of false positives because the
data isn't something that you you can't
computationally go in and figure out
what all the rules are and many things
just don't have an associated rule for
them for example something could be null
10 of the time
but that could vary you know
dramatically it could vary seasonally it
could vary with other factors and so you
can't put like a hard constraint around
that and so we realized that you should
be able to use machine learning to
understand and quantify the drift
in data arriving you know in real time
into data warehouses and and be able to
solve this problem in a much more
scalable way and so that was the kind of
product insight you know to solve the
problem of you know scale and diversity
of access
[Music]
so so obviously rules um in in your view
don't scale um completely um but i know
that you support them in an envelope um
so you have sort of both this machine
learning brain
that's looking for meaningful deviations
um statistical deviations across a set
of data plus you have sort of the the
marriage of a rule-based system
for areas where the client or the
customer
really sort of demand that or know you
know convincingly
sort of what they need to see
um so you've you've decided if i
understand correctly to sort of merge
both of those ideas
uh into one product is that fair
yeah actually there's three
so there's what we call unsupervised
learning which is you know i've got a
table i want to monitor it for adverse
changes
and just i'm going to let the algorithms
track changes in that data
then there's what we call metrics
monitoring
where a user is specifying a specific
metric could be a data quality metric
like the percentage of this null or it
could be a business metric you know how
often is my delivery on time
and be able to segment that metric you
know by geography or product type or
type of api event right and monitor
those metrics for unusual changes
and then there's validation rules where
i'm setting some hard and fast
constraint about the data
and what we realized
actually we began the company building
the unsupervised learning the machine
learning component the really kind of
novel deep ip
and it's an incredibly powerful tool but
it's not enough it's not a complete
product uh in order to really do
modeling well to do data quality
monitoring well you need to support all
three of these
um and so that's what we've built and
the way that they work together is the
unsupervised monitoring gives you like a
base layer of coverage and so we have
customers that have tens of thousands of
tables
being monitored with anomalous and you
can just light them all up and we've
made these machine learning algorithms
be
very very careful about never producing
false positive alerts
so they're only looking for the types of
changes that we know are adverse changes
things like you know suddenly having
duplicate data where you did not have
duplicate data before or um you know a
significant increase in null values
in a location so uh you know they're
constrained at really adverse types of
changes
and they work really hard to control for
the amount of chaos and background noise
in the data
so we use machine learning algorithms to
essentially search for potential data
quality issues and then we validate
those data quality issues by issuing
additional queries and getting a longer
time series history
of that data in order to validate that
this isn't a uh holiday change that's
always expected to happen as an example
so that is like your base layer of
coverage i like to think it could get
you to you know 60 70
of the value of data quality monitoring
um the metrics are an incredibly
important you know additional component
here because sometimes you care about
specific data in the table
a great deal right so if we go back to
instacart you know i cared a great deal
about that delivery time and so i really
wanted to pay very close attention to
that and i wanted to see how that
changed by market and you know by type
of shopper
and so within a novel though it's really
easy to specify a sql query that says
you know here's my time series structure
i've got a date column i've got these
you know five metrics i've got this
segmentation strategy a nominal will
build time series models to monitor all
of those metrics for unusual changes
and so that way
a subject matter expert
can point an envelope and say i want to
really closely watch this specific slice
of this data
then the validation rules they still
play an important part because the
validation rules is the only way that an
external user can bring their knowledge
of the real world of the way the app is
architected or you know the way users
are supposed to engage with the product
and make assertions about that in the
data
and so a common example would be what if
a column is already null 5 at the time
our machine learning algorithms aren't
going to alert on that they're going to
only alert if that goes up from 5 to 10
right it's going to alert on a change
same thing with metrics
in the validation rules a user can
specify this column should never be more
um and you bring that external knowledge
to bear on the data and so that's what
we see the system being really powerful
as it's a it's a foundation there's a
bunch of automated monitoring and then
subject matter experts can come in and
bring
their focus areas or their uh subject
matter expertise and express them as
rules on top of
what we're already doing
yep got it
um that sounds super super interesting
and powerful um and i know that
um you guys have spent a lot of time
sort of from a product perspective not
just you know from the back end
engineering monitoring bits and and
pieces but when it comes to like putting
these three
reviews of data quality or monitoring um
into one product i imagine that's a
little bit challenging to sort of
intuitively explain to a to a customer
to a user of the product on all in one
ui
um do you have any any tips or thoughts
on how you're successful in
accomplishing that
yeah so i think one
one important part of that is the fully
unsupervised
we've made a conscious decision to not
allow users to make any changes there
they begin with like factual
configuration about the table like how
is time measured in the table when do i
expect this data to arrive but then all
of the fully unsupervised monitoring is
completely automated the models are
rebuilt every day
um and you know they're going to catch
you know issues one time and then not
alert on them again because they're
constantly being rebuilt and there are
no knobs and dials there
um and we've worked really hard to
prevent those from ever ever sending
false positive notifications so
we could have gotten into i think a lot
of trouble if we made those highly
configurable customizable and lots of
dials because
users may not fully understand how they
work and can end up shooting themselves
in the foot
or missing issues
and so you know we work really hard to
take problems about data monitoring like
i'll give you an example a lot of data
and financial services never arrives on
saturdays and sundays
and so a naive system would say hey the
data's missing today mm-hmm um yeah or
is it a is it a holiday is it
being holiday
yeah so nine systems would send you
false positives
um uh another system might require the
user to go in and enter that information
right but a lot of users will they won't
know that but they won't think about
that as they're configuring the
monitoring they won't enter that until
they get the false positive
notifications and are already frustrated
by them and then will they know that
that's where they need to go to enter it
instead we do a model that predicts the
inter-arrival of data and we'll learn
that the data never arrives on holidays
or never arrives on weekends and so
that's actually okay and we don't need
to send a notification and so we work
really hard to make that unsupervised
part smart so that it can scale without
a lot of change
and then we have a very simple ui for
users to come in and add metrics and add
the validation rules
and the way i like to think about that
is
you know there's about two-thirds of
that functionality is no code right i
just am going to do three or four clicks
and i can monitor a metric by a segment
or three or four clicks and i've got a
specific validation rule you know from a
menu of a bunch of options but then the
last third is very technical highly
configurable you're you can drop in and
write complex sql
you can control your new machine
learning algorithms that are applied to
specific data um you can make you know
fine-tuned tweaks to how these checks
are working and so what we find is that
customers get this base layer of
coverage they don't have to worry about
lots of subject matter experts can come
in and use the no code part and then the
the real deep data science you know
analytics professionals that live and
breathe their table
right that they are they are critically
dependent upon that fact orders table
right for for a lot of what they're
doing they can come in and use the full
set of features and functionality to
express almost anything that they want
around you know what what about this
data is important what do i want to be
notified if it changes what are my
expectations about this data
got it
well i love how you've sort of
considered the surface area of the
product to support
everyone from
you know low code sort of probably
business users or perhaps data smes
all the way down to folks who are
more technical um i think you also have
an api don't you for sort of direct
interface from orchestrated data jobs um
talk to us about that yeah so you're the
exact same api that serves front-end
requests in our product
we expose through your pip installable
package
um and you can also interact with the
api in other classical ways um and that
api you know allows you to do everything
that you could do in the ui
um you know through code or
configuration and broadly we see three
different types of activities happen in
the api
one is configuration
so you know i'm a new customer or i've
added a new data warehouse or a new team
and i've got a thousand tables that i
want to set up monitoring on i can use
the api to programmatically control that
configuration um or you know if i want
to have a
hook in my cicd process such that
anytime a new data model comes into
existence i want to set up monitoring on
a nominal that can be fully automated
so that's the configuration piece the
next piece is the execution of the
checks
and so this is interesting we actually
designed a nominal load to be
an independent platform
watching the data it's it's like back to
the dr seuss who's watching the watcher
um you know kind of uh comic the watcher
watcher right you don't want to have
your airflow dag
be responsible for monitoring the data
if a part of what you want to monitor is
whether or not the airflow data
completed
and so it's actually helpful to have an
independent orchestration system which
is integrated into an envelope that's
observing the data watching for it to
arrive
and so you don't have to to to you know
orchestrate things yourselves by default
anomaly takes care of it but there are
times when
in your dag you want to change the
behavior of what you're doing with the
data based upon the results of data
quality
so you know if i find a material anomaly
in this data set that i was about to
publish through reverse etl to some
partner that i care about um you know i
want to i want to stop the processing
and you know immediately get somebody on
call in order to address that issue or i
want to quarantine bad data so when our
checks fail we'll give you you know sql
that'll allow you to quarantine the bad
data and you move on with data that is
good
so that's where we we see the
orchestration layer um and the ability
to execute checks being really important
through the api the third piece is
getting data out
oftentimes you want to do an integration
with your data catalog or you have an
internal tool that you want to use to
show you know what's what's uh healthy
in your data warehouse we've added a lot
of these visualizations dashboards
within anomalous so increasingly our
customers don't even you know want to do
that or need to do that in case they do
they can get all of the data out of the
platform through the api
got it
all right very cool
um well i i wanna you know talk a little
bit about
data quality inside an org and take a
little bit of a step back because
obviously
you know through a product such as this
you've
discovered
sort of lots of constituents
across an organization that potentially
need to collaborate on data quality and
so
um
i think we're all learning as an
industry that this is not just the
domain of
the data engineer or the devops person
right i think in your article
you talk about well that's just like
asking the the factory
um you know operator in a factory
um to check the quality of the materials
coming through the machine that they
they only sort of watch the performance
of the
machine itself they don't actually check
the quality of the goods coming coming
through the machine or being processed
by the machine that requires a different
sort of expertise i thought that was a
particularly good
analogy and i think that gets us to this
notion that
um you know
it takes a village probably to to sort
of establish data quality inside your
company um talk to us about that and who
you see is the the main players um in
this in these scenarios
yeah it's it's
a really important point and it takes a
village for two reasons
one because
different people are going to have
different understanding of even what
should be tested why and how
but also when things go wrong
you need to make sure you've got the
right audience reviewing and triaging
that who's going to be able to
understand well is this a is this a real
issue and if so
what do we do about it
so the constituents that we see there
there is the data engineering um or you
know increasingly analytics engineering
um which is depending upon the
organization can range from you know
responsible for infrastructure and for
the movement of data
through to actually creating you know
more complex and rich data sets and
you're having more subject matter
expertise about the data itself
kind of varieties of of roles there so
that's one constituent they tend to care
a lot about is data arriving on time
um is the volume of records what i would
expect are there any obvious missing
segments is the schema appropriate etc
the next constituent is what i call the
data scientist the analyst the machine
learning engineer
these are people who are real data
professionals right they live and
breathe the data their job revolves
around the data
and they will tend to have very deep
close relationships to specific tables
in the data warehouse they will
intimately know and understand the
structure and content of this data and
they're the ones that are going to go in
and add really complex rules validations
metrics they're going to consume you
know some of the most complex machine
learning uh identified anomalies to
understand are they meaningful or
adverse for their teams
then you have what i would call data
savvy professionals in the organization
these could be a product manager
evaluating a b test results
right and wanting to understand is the a
b test uh is there some difference
between the population right and is the
a b test set up and is the data flowing
correctly so they'll be able to make
decisions off of it
it could be somebody in operations or in
marketing right making decisions using
data a classic example at instacart
we had people that would launch physical
markets you know decide what zip codes
in cincinnati should we support with
instacart they were critically dependent
upon data because we would collect every
time a user came to the website
they would put in their zip code to
identify what stores they belong to and
of course we would want to launch the
zip codes that people were putting into
the website right because they want the
service there and so that was a critical
data pipeline that directly informed
those folks at one point that data
pipeline stopped getting updated and it
got switched to something else and they
were still doing sql queries on the old
one such that they were launching data
using data that was six months out of
date
and one of the biggest growth changes at
instacart during our tenure there was
just fixing that so they can use the
right data um so you've got you know
those three constituents data engineers
um and uh analytics engineers data
scientists are kind of you know folks
are really dedicated to the data and
then just folks that are using the data
to do their job and what we found is
using
slack microsoft teams and creating
dedicated channels for narrow topics
of data quality is really powerful and
so most of our customers they'll have
sort of from five to maybe 50 you know
different topical channels you know uh
at inscart you might have one just
related to catalog data received from
our uh you know retail partners you know
another one related just to logistics
data about delivery times right another
one related to utilization of shoppers
another one related to customer
satisfaction data um and within those
channels you'll have all of the people
within the organization that have a
vested interest participating in that
channel and then within the data quality
monitoring platform you want to be able
to route the alerts and the
responsibility of the data and the
resolution flows in through those
channels and so that provides the
visibility in the organizational
structure
it's more about the kind of topic of the
data and the subject matter expertise
than necessarily your role
and so talk to us what happens after
that because i know that you're a
proponent of thinking of
data issues in sort of a triage
um
you know format um how do you like how
do you see
successful teams responding to a data
incident like what what does that entail
and what should that entail going
forward
so i think the first thing uh and this
is a failure with many approaches as a
failure at instacart
is it's not enough to tell you
that there are you know five duplicate
records in table x today or that column
y
you know mean
you know shot up by twenty percent
it's actually pretty annoying
to get alerts where that's all the
context that you
and so the first thing that we realized
with a nomilo is visualization uh and
context around these issues is is
critical and so we've really architected
the engineering of an envelope and the
platform itself to make it really easy
to create visualizations that are
interactive
and super customized and relevant to the
nature of the issue
so probably have a hundred different
types of visualizations
that can appear in the slack
notification to help explain the issue
and we work really hard to go inside the
data itself to help explain it and so as
an example if we suddenly find that
there's you know two percent of values
in this table are null
well you can go in and you can look at
the records and kind of scrub through
the records and squint at them and try
to figure out like why are these null
values why are they there what what
characterizes them is it something about
the location is something about the the
time stamp is it something about you
know this entity or this relationship
like and you can go blind trying to do
that in part because you actually need
to compare it to good data right you
need to have some reference
to be able to say well why is this data
different from the other good data and
that's very hard for a human to do and
so we build algorithms to do that in an
automated way we call it a root cause
analysis we scan the entirety of the
table and identify any segments that are
strongly correlated with the bad data
and we just provide that directly to the
person consuming the alert
and so you know why i'm i'm hoping on
all of this is because if you're getting
alerts and those alerts don't come with
context and require you to do a lot of
work to understand the issue
it's really painful and you're going to
end up ignoring them
right if instead they come with context
and you can quickly say actually this
isn't a big deal i expected this to
happen
or i understand why this happened it
happened because of x we've already got
a fix in you know in progress you know
uh to solve that or this is totally
unexpected and it's happening in a place
that's actually really serious and i'm
pretty sure my ceo is going to email me
about this in three hours
wildly different right if you if you get
that information in just a minute
instead of requiring the consumer of the
alert to do three hours to do that
i think the whole game changes so you're
putting the right actionable information
in the context with the alert is like
the first mission critical thing from
there you need to have a triage system
and so you know within anomalies this
concept of uh there's all the data that
you're not monitoring there's the data
that you're monitoring and it's healthy
there's the data that you're monitoring
and something has failed something has
gone awry
and then there's a subset of those that
you actually need to take action on
right something needs to be done there
they're a serious issue that requires
some work and then there's the ones that
are actually then resolved and now you
know what the issue uh is and you've
resolved it and so an envelope is really
about helping you to get into that
triage state of is this something that i
should be paying attention to
um am i investigating it um or have i
decided that it is an issue and i've now
handed it off to the appropriate team
and so we call that you know triage
where you can acknowledge or you can
hand off and the handoff would be you
know creating a pagerduty event if you
know somebody on the infrastructure team
needs to respond to something or
creating a servicenow ticket for you
know uh someone to negotiate with the
vendor why the api changed and get you
know the engineering team
uh through a jira ticket to make the
change to actually reflect the new api
right so that's where the actual work
happens and so we see we see anomalo as
being let us help you understand
is it a real problem
where did it happen and who do you need
to talk to and then get that next set of
discussions happening through the
appropriate system
yeah it makes you realize how many
considerations there are in building a
data monitoring system and it's no
wonder that um orgs with their cobble
together sql strips you know just don't
scale
over time
yeah no absolutely yeah
great well um jeremy we're almost out of
time um but i just wanted to ask you you
know sort of a founder-oriented question
um because we have lots of founders on
the show who are
equally great technical professionals
and
i'm wondering you know for you as a
technical person as a data scientist
former cto um what was the what was the
most challenging part about starting a
new company as a technical founder
yeah interesting so
i mean there are all sorts of technical
challenges you know behind the scenes
that are really
fun um
some of them can be quite difficult uh
you know the the one that that gets me
constantly is just how
how much variation there is in the uh
the exact implementation and sql
dynamics across the different cloud data
warehouses so building a system that's
going to execute arbitrarily complex sql
across all the different data warehouse
providers and work at dale and all of
the edge cases it's just um you know
this mountain of edge cases because we
could be working with healthcare data we
could be working with financial services
data identity management data um it
could be in bigquery snowflake athena uh
it could be impresto it could be an
azure synapse you know so many different
edge cases there
um so as a technical challenge that's
been something that's been recurring
uh is you know how do you how do you
really effectively solve that um but i
think that that pales in comparison to
the overall startup journey right
um and the ups and downs of it you know
this is this is um
you know uh well known but as a founder
you'll have uh a day where it's like
everything is amazing this is fantastic
i'm so excited things are going so well
and then the next day's like everything
is falling apart
why did i ever decide to do this and so
being able to manage your energy through
that especially when searching for
product market fit
uh i think was really really uh
challenging it was a very good is a
great growth experience i really enjoyed
it um but it was quite challenging and
uh you know the opportunity to wear lots
of different hats and have real
accountability and ownership for things
i think is a fantastic experience so you
know overall it's an amazing thing it is
it is a very tough thing to do
yeah for sure
um well yeah thanks for your honesty
there and um i know it's uh quite a road
to the founder and there's lots of folks
in our community who aspire to to do the
same
um so if folks want to reach out to you
and get more information
um about anomalo um or chat with you
about any other data monitoring
questions they might have what's the
best way for them to do that
yeah so if if they want to reach out to
me twitter is probably the best place to
find me and communicate with me
um i'm on twitter at jeremystem so
j-e-r-e-m-y-s-t-a-n
uh and if you want to reach out to us at
anomalou you just go to our website it's
a-n-o-m-a-l oh shoot i messed it up i
knew i was gonna do that it's a-n-o-m-a
great awesome go there and reach out to
us
i think we spelled it right in the
youtube description so um folks folks
should be able to find you there yeah um
well jeremy this has been really fun
thanks for chatting with me today and
thanks for all your contributions to the
community over the years yeah thank you
pete for having me and thank you for
building this great community it's it's
an amazing asset for everyone to learn
from so really appreciate it
awesome
um and to our listeners we'll have
another dc thursday coming up in two
weeks on the 5th of may
with neha pawar from the apache pinot
project
so don't forget to subscribe so that
you're notified when we go back on the
air
and
we'll see you soon thanks for tuning in